in the movie with riddler he's talking
to his followers and he's talking about
how in the weeks and months they've been
talking how long do you
did you ever discuss how long has the
riddler been planning all of the events
that he was doing did it ever like did
you ever say it's been like a year
did you ever figure that out yeah i mean
i think i think that um you know and
this is true of the comics right there's
so many comics where you see that the
rogue gallery creates themselves in
response to this appearance of this
masked vigilante called batman in gotham
and so
i
he's sort of in a certain way inspired
by the presence of this vigilante and
he's he's that's happened within the
last two years so he this has been the
desire to understand
what's happened to him since he was a
child and why this place was such a
rough place for him and why he had such
a dark sort of existence and a brutal
existence in this brutal place
is that that goes all the way back to
him being a kid and that's where the ave
maria sort of stuff comes in but him his
plan and the idea that he could somehow
um
use what he had discovered as a forensic
as a forensic um uh accountant when that
word renewal came across his desk it
wasn't wasn't even on his desk he looked
across and saw something that haunted
him from his childhood and suddenly
because
his one strength you know he's not like
batman who sort of works on himself
physically so that he can become very
powerful and can endure and he can take
almost anything but he is that way
mentally and when he he sees the
patterns of things it starts to make
sense of his life and that has been i
would say that that has probably taken
place over the last couple years and
that the presence of batman caused him
to
see a way that he might be able to
reveal the truth in a brutal way about
this city so it's been going on for you
know
paul and i talked for a while about this
idea about how
he came across that evidence how he sort
of without anyone anyone knowing started
going on this kind of forensic path and
learn the truth of this city and then
he's kind of trying to take batman on
that same path and expose the depth of
corruption of this place
you